[Music]
somebody's house Thole into sex day like
I am into it you know or breeze astern
ran upstairs to go put some pants on so
she does straddle Pauly like that horse
is going down in the bootcamp okay what
do you guys think of this position
pretty cool you look excited pull me
back up what is your favorite position
okay so the most intimate position
obviously is if we do it like missionary
yeah show us so you'd like to be on top
mm-hmm
what's the makeup sex like for you to
good I bet it's phenomenal yeah because
the picture I see with YouTube when you
guys are good you're really good yeah
and then the fight comes and you don't
hit her physically but you hit her with
the emotional I'm out of here which is
just like a physical blow to a woman
with abandonment issues yeah so then we
got the breakup and then comes the
reconnection yeah and I don't want you
to get stuck in that spin cycle and not
being able to push the pause button and
pull yourself out of that Holly and
Aubrey if they can give more power to
them listening and growing together as
they do their sex they wouldn't be here
[Music]